bill de blasio was just asked how it
came to be the case
that he painted a giant black lives
matter mural down the streets of new
york
because if you want a mural in new york
city
there's a process to go through for that
so a reporter just recently asked the
bolshevik mayor of new york
what process he went through to put that
to put that mural up and you know what
he said
he said he didn't go through a process
because you know this
this moment suspends all the rules of
politics we haven't said
no to people who said if you want to
apply you can apply but there's a
process
look the fact is that what i decided to
do
with the black lives matter murals and
this came out of a meeting at gracie
mansion
weeks ago with community leaders and
activists who said this would be such an
important thing for this city to declare
officially that is something again
transcends all normal realities because
we are in a moment of history where this
had to be said and done that's a
decision i made
but the normal process continues for
anyone who wants to apply
the normal process continues for all the
peasants
yeah the normal process is for all you
little people not for me i do whatever i
want
because this moment transcends all
political questions meaning it
transcends all of the law
all of the constitution this moment it
tri
it needed to be said right now by the
city of new york
that black lives matter let me ask you a
question
does anybody on planet earth think that
new york city does not believe that
black lives matter
uh no i think we all know that new york
city thinks black lives matter
if the mayor is right in his ridiculous
political view that real
liberals love black people and
conservatives hate black people new
york's one of the most liberal places in
the
in the world so you're good right
any any way you slice it by de blasio's
own logic he would be fine
but he's just another petty progressive
demagogue who believes
that the democratic order the rule of
law is fine it's a fine facade for
all the ruffians to kind of keep them
amused and distracted but him he knows
what's best
he knows that he gets to violate the law
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you